britain is observing ten days of
national mourning that will culminate
with the queen's state funeral and as
the collection of flowers grows outside
balmoral castle the royal family's home
in scotland the public is about to get
its first formal chance
to say goodbye to queen elizabeth
elizabeth palmer is in edinburgh this
morning elizabeth good morning to you
good morning the official date of the
funeral has not been announced
at least formally by the palace but it's
expected to be the 19th of september
that's a monday meanwhile uh the complex
and very spectacular
preparations for it are about to be
unveiled here in scotland
queen elizabeth spent many happy
vacations at her estate balmoral with
its 50 000 acres of scottish countryside
and a castle
it's where just this week she received
britain's new prime minister liz truss
and only two days later she died when
the archbishop gently sets this splendid
emblem on the queen's head from the
beginning of her reign she starred in
and understood the power of pageantry as
a national spectacle to draw the united
kingdom together
the queen's body is expected to arrive
soon here at hollywood house the royal
residence in edinburgh and that's when
the complex choreography of her funeral
preparations will unfold in the public
eye preparations that the queen herself
helped to plan
ever since she died on thursday scottish
people and visitors from around the
world have been leaving flowers and
messages they brim with admiration and
respect for a woman who always put duty
first
and perfectly balanced mystery and
accessibility
after a service in edinburgh's gothic st
giles cathedral the queen's coffin will
go on to london
she'll lie in state at westminster hall
in the parliament buildings for four
days
and then her body will be escorted the
short distance to westminster abbey for
a state funeral
the last one was in 1965 for the great
wartime prime minister winston churchill
57 years on the queens will be a
magnificent prelude to her burial at
windsor castle
i've been reading some of the notes
among the flowers behind me and one of
them sums up the general tone perfectly
it says simply thank you for your
service ma'am rest in peace michelle
wow eloquent liz palmer thank you